[Music]
if you're wondering how new technology
can make your life easier we've got some
answers for you this morning from a
countertop dishwasher to a robot that
can give you massages okay okay
we're getting a look at some of this
year's latest gadgets the consumer
technology association's annual
conference called ces kicks off today
preparations have been made in las vegas
where the event will be in person and
virtual this year as covet cases soared
big names like google microsoft amazon
and gm pulled out from in-person
portions cnet's editor-at-large brian
cooley joins us right now good morning
brian how are you doing
good morning nate i'm doing fine i am
not in las vegas i'm one of those many
uh people who decided to cover the show
but not go to the show
it's all right you got the technology
that will get you covered um so talk to
me about these monitors that i'm hearing
about that could change the way you work
at home and watch tv yeah look at these
they're very enveloping the idea here
across the tv industry these are being
showed by lg is that you'll have a
monitor that is so large you look at
that and so curved under and above you
that it's almost like a place more than
just a device you look down you see the
road you look up you see the trees and
of course you look forward and you have
a peloton-like view this is part of the
pelotonization of so many products
brian that is so cool looking also looks
very big let's talk about the health
aspect i swear by the apple watch i wear
it every day it gives me so much
information i know people wear fitbits
but i'm hearing you have something there
called a ring that can also monitor your
health how does that work
yeah so there are there was a ring out a
couple of years ago we talked about uh
gale that was a little on the pricey
side called ura this is a new one from a
company called movano uh not yet on the
market it's promised to be a lot less
expensive and yet still monitor all of
those indications you see on the screen
activity respiration heart rate or
problems with your heart rhythm and then
in the future potentially blood pressure
and blood glucose that remains kind of a
holy grail still in the industry the
idea here is unlike people like you gail
who adopted smart watches early a lot of
people have got no health wearable on
them at all and we've got to get at
least one health wearable on everybody
in the next 10 years because it's
ridiculous that we only get our signals
checked once a year at the doctor
i know i fell recently and the watch
started talking to me saying you know
seems like you fell are you okay and i
was shocked i go yes i'm fine don't call
anybody don't call anybody but how do
you make sure that you're
how do you make sure that your
health information is secure
the two main things here first of all
many of these devices are covered by
hipaa the federal law that secures your
health data if they connect to a doctor
or connect to your health records which
many of these do now that's not
considered uncommon anymore or at the
very least when you set it up make sure
you take your time the first time and
uncheck any boxes about data sharing
that you're not comfortable with a lot
of folks blow through that
all right brian we are also hearing
about what is being described as a
human-like robot i think we'll judge
that when we see it what can you tell us
about this thing
yes sit down for this one tony it's a
real seriously human-looking robot this
is called a mika from a company called
engineered arts uk company look at that
so what they're saying is look we've
made a lot of progress in a.i the
intelligence that powers various robots
that we've talked about over the years
but where's the progress in the physical
sort of nuance of them and that's what
they're doing here saying the physical
nuance needs to be as good as the
intelligence and that we're building
into these otherwise the whole sort of
idea of it being convincing starts to
fall apart this is an extremely
realistic looking device to be in front
of now it's not going to be coming to
markets or homes anytime soon but you
can see where we're going
yeah brian what does it do i don't know
what it does well i want to get in on
one particular robot that i know what it
does it doesn't look like a human being
it's a massage robot we showed some
video of it just at the top of the
segment there it is
uh what do we know about that we know
what it does right this gives you a
massage this is either the best or the
worst thing in the world of massage
depending on how you feel about a human
massage therapist some people say that's
the best thing about it i've got this
person who's working out all these nuts
and kinks others say i don't want to be
mostly disrobed in front of anybody i
don't know so depending on where you
fall on the massage
experience spectrum this could be great
or it could make absolutely no sense to
you and it's from a company that builds
massage robots
when it comes to robots i feel like i've
seen this in a movie before um and it
didn't turn out good but brian cooley
thank you so much um we appreciate you
joining us